is it worth waiting for the M3 MacBook
Air or should you just buy an M1 or M2
MacBook Air for absolutely insane prices
I'm talking 750 for an M1 air or $88.99
for a 13in M2 and 1,50 for this 15in M2
a which I absolutely love we have done a
ton of testing on the new M3 chip so I
want to give you guys my honest feedback
on the performance and if it's worth it
depending ending on what you do I want
to start out with SSD speed because the
M1 smokes the M2 and the M3 machines
because those come with a single nand if
you have a 256 gig setup and believe it
or not this can actually make a
difference in real world use and you can
buy a discounted 16 gig 1 tbte 15in air
right now for 250 off and that right
there could make it also worth buying
one right now now as far as single core
performance the M3 chip definitely
starts to take the lead and when I use
it I do notice that it's a little bit
snappier but most people that are
upgrading from an older Intel Mac or
Windows machine will not notice even the
M1 MacBook Air that's now 3 years old um
that will be super fast for multi-core
CPU we go from 8,600 to 9700 and then
11,800 .99 for the M3 chip so that is
38% faster than the M1 and about 20 than
the M2 of course this tests a wide
variety of tasks so we'll see how that
affects real world usage now as far as
Graphics this is where gets interesting
because our M1 has a seven core the m2s
can come with an eight or a 10 and then
we have a 10 for the M3 we see 25,000
for the M1 39,000 for the M2 2 AC core
and then
47,000 for the M3 now that is a really
good spread there but if you are buying
a 15in it automatically gets the best
graphics and then that jumps to
45,000 just slightly behind the new M3
chip so the performance is practically
the same and if we look at graphics
performance per dollar the 15in M2
actually wins by a good margin so when
the M3 comes out for these MacBook airs
you are going to get similar performance
but you're not going to get these insane
sales now even if you don't buy a new
Mac you need our sponsor's app clean my
Mac X when we clean up and refresh our
offline spaces like for example our set
here it really brings positivity and
gets you ready for work and the same
thing happens when you organize and
refresh your online setup you're just
more motivated when you have a routine
and your Mac is running great clean my
Mac makes this easy and smart scan does
three jobs with one click to clean up
protect and speed up your Mac all in
just seconds while you're grabbing a
coffee I've used it for 4 years now
because it is fast and easy so I know my
Mac is running its best making me
actually excited to jump into a new
project it's deleted a bunch of hidden
junk files I couldn't find and has
countless helpful tools and features I
use the memory free up button all the
time which is especially important for
base back max get your Fresh Start in
2024 with clean my Mac X try it with a
7-Day free trial and use my promo code
below to get up to five licenses with a
30% discount now when we look at gaming
performance the M3 does start to get a
little bit more distance compared to the
10 core M2 and this is where I need to
talk about throttling because unlike the
14-in with the M3 that we were testing
the MacBook airs they can heat up for
long sessions especially like if you're
gaming now I really took this into
consideration when while I was doing
this testing to see will we still get M3
performance in a fan lless machine and
thankfully we will because if you take a
look at the wattage when we're putting a
full load on these systems the M3 uses
the same exact power as the M2 because
it's a 3 nanm design it is more
efficient so even though you have more
performance the power usage stays the
same so if you were worrying about the
MacBook airs throttling and you not
getting much performance because of the
fanless design no the performance should
stay the same and that is killer news
and in cinebench 2024 the M1 and M2 are
very close but the M3 is
45% faster and remember this is the same
amount of power usage so if you really
Hammer your CPU 100% for a long time
that is going to be a noticeable
difference with that said for regular
people that are web browsing and doing
things like that the M1 does fall behind
and speed a little bit then the M2 and
M3 are very close and I'll will say even
the M1 most people are going to be
perfectly happy and fine with it and
when we tested figma a professional 3D
web design application with this project
provided to us by 5 designs one of the
best design studios in California all
these machines were fairly smooth and
the actual time it took to render these
12 high resolution layers the difference
was not that great the M2 was fairly
close and here's the performance
difference in xcode if you do coding so
yes the M3 is faster but it's not a
massive difference and there's a lot of
people that are coding on a 15in air or
even a 13-inch that are very happy with
it and also for those that do logic well
here the M1 and M2 don't have that big
of a difference the M3 does actually
excel in the New Logic Benchmark 2 which
you guys can look up um everything that
goes into that but that is already a ton
of tracks and even the M1 performs so
much better than the older Intel
MacBooks now for blender rendering this
is where things get crazy because in the
BMW test we have a massive difference
the M3 is more than twice as fast than
the M2 which is a little bit faster than
the M1 and that's because the graphics
pipeline has been really improved we
have rate tracing now with M3 which can
help in some games although the graphics
performance isn't insane here um that's
where we had an overhaul so if you do
blender 3D rendering you want to do it
on a MacBook Air well you absolutely
need to wait for the M3 version now for
photo editing this is where it gets
crazy because the M1 base model actually
beats out the M2 base model and then the
M3 is a bit faster now that's because of
the singleand SSD in here uh and the
fact that it's 8 gigs of RAM I can't
believe believe that the M1 is actually
faster uh and with the M3 even it's very
bottleneck because if you upgrade to 16
gigs of RAM you dramatically improve
your speeds down to a minute and 6
seconds but the M2 version it gets a
minute and 16 so it's just slightly
slower if you get 16 gigs and of course
right now you can get a great price on
an upgraded one so don't think that the
performance difference is that massive
now for video editing if you're working
with standard 4K the difference in
exporting is not there at all and yes
this has two lets applied color grading
and film grin so it's not just a regular
file there's a lot to be processed and
they all handle regular 4K editing now
with that said if you are somebody that
works with prores that's where you want
to ignore the M1 because it doesn't have
prores encoders and it is much slower
than the other two which have very
similar times now I also have to add
that the M1 does not have Max safe so
that is a convenience feature feure but
it also opens up the other two ports for
you to be able to connect other devices
and I love ma safe we also have a
brighter larger display um the battery
life is really excellent and with that
said the M3 version of the airs will
have roughly 1 to two hours better Real
World battery life because it is more
efficient when you're not doing tough
tasks so that is something to think
about but the M2 versions are already
very excellent in battery life as well
and this is what brings me to kind of
the conclusion we looked at all this
performance and yes in certain cases it
absolutely matters to wait for the M3
but in a lot of cases the difference is
very small while you're saving a good
amount of money and that money could go
go towards upgrading your SSD and your
RAM and that value is excellent so I
will say honestly even though we love
computer upgrades and new tech coming
out new tech is always coming out
Apple's already planning 2 nanometer and
now t SMC is talking about 1.4 nanometer
or something um upgrades always happen
so if you're always waiting for the next
thing you're just stuck waiting and I
think for 1,050 bucks this M2 15in is
incredible such a great value and if you
can spend a little bit more you can
upgrade it personally I think for most
people that are looking to get a MacBook
Air that are doing regular tasks I would
not wait unless you do one of the few
things where we saw a big difference go
ahead and check out my 6month review of
this machine I'll have it right over
there click that Circle above to
subscribe This One Max and I'll see you
in the next video